I'm midway through my Great Escape to
Thailand Thai food is much loved back
home but I've discovered as much more to
it than I ever realized Thai food in the
UK weighs about that but it's nowhere
near as spicy as it is over here in a
way it's dumb down to sort of suit the
British pub which is a great shame I've
learned some of the secrets of authentic
spicy Thai curry and now I want to
master southern Thai seafood
I'm heading 1,200 kilometres south to
the crabby coast where they serve some
of the best in the world today it's the
annual food festival
I'm hitching a ride with a crack squad
of local home cooks who have high hopes
of winning top prize in today's fish
paste competition so - no I'm saying
goes pitch pitch high pitch deep voice
okay here we go the home cooks are
Thailand's answer to the Women's
Institute but they have an open-door
policy would be any other guys there
cooking or will I be the only guy only
me yes what I was
fish paste is the bedrock of Thai
seafood dishes and is an important part
of my education who's the expert here
the queen of the fish pace amazing
amazing amazing
[Music]
okay let's go the festival is like the
crabby food Olympics with lots of
incredible categories so rice paneling
competition youngest entrance 94 amazing
oh cool thank you thank you amazing look
look at that immaculate there's some
very serious competition going on here
sad music we're up next damn it's time
for the main event
are we ready oh please yeah don't worry
about it yeah yeah I feel like I've got
suspenders on none is trying to make me
look as pretty as he is or pretty stupid
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to learn how to make my own paste
so the group has split into team mama in
one corner and team Ramsey in the other
thanks oh thank you garlic in yes I'm
relying upon my teammates for the recipe
so far we've got a garlic that young
fragrant garlic tumeric look at it
useful okay oh Jesus
next the star ingredient fish guts
[Music]
fermented for two weeks right makes the
fetus out the spicy paste goes in and
then some dried fish to strengthen the
flavor the recipe is uncomplicated and
very straightforward but the secret is
is getting the balance right I'm going
to check out the competition
[Music]
very good very spicy
[Music]
my god that's spicy thank you very much
oh my god
time to find out what they think of mine
[Music]
yeah yeah oh the faces lavell Kim Kim
Kim salty I think I need mamas expert
opinion what does that mean
salty damn damn damn damn your mum's is
not that salty your mom's got that sort
of rich texture there huh mama is yeah
amazing it's got a nice sort of salty
sweet sour flavor as instantly it's too
salty well Mama's in with a good chance
even if I'm not the judges of cool time
hello lucky number 9 it's slightly salty
but it's got the back up with a
sweetness as well please don't look
confused look happy
I'm very hard to be here good luck it's
out of my hands now we wait for the
judges to deliver the verdict
like a my label yeah I'm gonna pop like
a cheesy
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not just me
sadly team mama have been picked to the
post as well make sure come again
first and we'll take second okay well
done okay thank you
this must be some of the stress-free
cooking I've ever been involved in
because everyone's having fun relaxed
and they're so generous with their
offerings in terms of the knowledge the
most important thing is I had the
winning recipe now I just have to put
that into practice and kick with Dan's
butt
unbelievable time for a beer a big one